okay wait so I know I told you I love
Serena you can tell me it's just me and
you nobody's watching is she unretiring
I mean what's happening girl we coming
back
I said right away I was like nah she
ain't done she's like yeah I I think I
can do some more so we'll see
[Music]
so much to discuss because I'm super
fascinated by how your life changed but
we all saw the moment that your life
changed so tell me what your life was
like before the US Open and what your
life is like now
great great questions like I mean going
in before like you know it was a good
tennis player or whatever but
um after we I felt like I became a legit
star
um which was because it's just wild to
see you know two two and a half weeks
spent
um yeah it was it was insane did you
feel like that was going to happen in
the moment of the open or did that not
hit you until after I felt good momentum
going in but you know you never know
right like I mean the things you wish
for but you never know and
um yeah I think in the middle of it I
was like something cool could really
happen here yeah okay well we have to
discuss all the stars that were rooting
for you uh Michelle Obama number one who
was actually at the game rooting for you
did you all get to have like a
substantial conversation was it really
quick what was that moment yeah yeah
yeah
um after after the match he went wanted
to come see me after the semi-final
match and I was I was upset and then
someone tapped me like Michelle wants to
see you and I like put on a new shirt I
was like yeah I'm good my mom was
already there she was super excited and
my mom was doing more talking than I was
she was just so excited to meet her and
um she was just saying how proud she was
and we spoke for a good amount of time
and uh that was I was like you you
coming out to be here means the world to
me so yeah and I know you've spoken
about this a bit but I think there were
so many people who wouldn't maybe call
themselves tennis fans but they became
Francis fans and I think that's
something that's that's really important
why do you think it is crucial that we
have people like you and Tennis so that
people just become more interested in
the players specifically 100 is the you
know the player the you know the story
and what have you you know like just
little things like I mean Serena if
Serena wasn't Serena and Venus wasn't
Venus I probably wouldn't play tennis
would I so you know they opened that
door up and I think representation is so
big especially the predominantly white
sport to be like oh no we actually can
do this and go through this you know
Avenue which is tennis and
um I'm happy and and it was cool to see
people who wouldn't walk Santa's a day
in their life but would because friends
TF was playing so that meant a lot to me
yeah absolutely okay so you talked about
tennis being a predominantly white sport
I think that you know we all know that
but for someone who's in it why would
you say that is
so I think it's it's access right it's
it's tough to you know I mean even if
you say here in New York like getting
core time is super expensive then you
got to pay for rackets drinking shoes
apparel
um it's very very tough rather than
growing up in the hood like you gotta
you get a basketball you get a hoop like
playing 505 you get an open field get a
football you're playing football like I
think that's why we go to those Sports
and
um yeah I mean it's just
people like LeBron and stuff like that
like it's easier to go that route so
yeah because and and this is something
that I have talked about a bit it's like
whenever we are discussing black people
that are in predominantly white spaces a
lot of things that we hear is like they
are the first or they are the first sins
and while I think that that is really
beautiful that you know we end up making
it to that moment sometimes it's sad
that we are you know you were the first
in that moment since Arthur Ashe I'm
sure you're proud of that I mean it's
crazy but it's like way way too long
right yeah
um let's not wait another 50 years for
to do something that special again I
totally agree yeah and you spoke about
this a little bit but Serena and Venus I
think you can really directly Trace how
many people picked up the sports simply
because they watch them like we talk
about the butterfly effect and like one
person doing one thing is the Catalyst
for so many people to do it but you
could argue they changed like a lot of
the lives of black people that play this
sport does that make sense they change
the game completely yeah yeah
um the way it was looked at you know I
mean everybody I mean and that's why
people even came out to this year
someone to watch me play because it was
also Serena's you know last one so it
was it was super cool that kind of like
flopped Twist of it and but yeah what
they did I mean Williams sisters I mean
that's they're so iconic you know even
because like they're like big sis to me
now both of them but like having
conversations with them I'm like you
guys are just on a whole different level
so yeah I mean how crazy is it that
that's your life now Serena Williams is
like your big sis
definitely definitely like when we hang
out I'm like yeah this is definitely not
your everyday thing but yeah I'll take
it for what it is yeah what have you
learned from her in your personal
interactions
um I'm super excited how she like
carries yourself because obviously you
just pulled a million directions
everyone wants her time and seeing how
she is you know really moves with such a
small crowd I mean people that she can
really trust you know dearly with
anything
um but yeah everyone's and everyone's
got to roll there's no like it's kind of
like
hang around is kind of kind of guys
which is pretty interesting because
um everybody starts to be wants to be
around for a reason once you're doing
really well so
um he's got to finish that up yeah so as
you continue to like move and navigate
within this world I know you mentioned
Serena as one but who are some stars
that you look to and say this is what I
want my public life to look like I like
the way that they carry themselves to
other people yeah bro you've seen that
hug the other day yeah I did yeah Brown
was he's definitely definitely that guy
for me
um yeah I love I love how he did it I
mean with his boys You Know Rich math
like that's that that's crazy and seeing
what they did is insane I think he
actually had a complete blueprint Jay-Z
also I'm a massive fan hope so I think
those two are like the most iconic
people with me yeah okay so I know
you're a big LeBron fan and we know that
he is also a fan of you walk me through
like the timeline of interactions
because I know it was when you did the
celebration at first then you're in the
open so tell me how it went for you the
first time y'all communicated to this
hug uh that happened in DC I thought it
was so long like I have the hug that I
was telling my boys like finally we got
we got to do it like just meet each
other but yeah yeah um when he first did
it I was like man this is insane like I
didn't even know you watched tennis or
like no carrot and then then he did it
again and then like this year when I was
the biggest like day of my life when he
tweeted out
uh I was like that was the first thing I
saw right when I sat down
um in the locker room and I'm like I
gotta meet this guy like we like now
like we gotta we gotta like meet so yeah
where the schedule came out December 4th
Circle within hit my guys I'm like I'm
on the wood like like this is way
planned this is way way planned and like
usually like shoot around I'll be like
hang out with Brad obviously I'm super
close to Brad and stuff shoot around I
seen Brad I was like bro I'm with the
Lakers today like I don't care bro and
it was cool because right before I seen
Russ I was sitting next to us during
Fashion Week so like that open the door
for it a little bit but it was crazy
because it brought to this whole shoot
around he locked eyes on me like a ton
of times I was like wow is he not gonna
say what's up and at the end when he's
walking out he's like no I see you like
he's like I was but I was locked in and
then we did it so that was cool that's
fire so what did you all Exchange in
that moment was it just hi I'm proud of
you yeah exactly exactly it's like yeah
finally he even said finally get to meet
you and
um he's like man keep going so proud of
you and then that was that was kind of
it obviously he's about to go to war but
I was like man
that was like I guess you finally
happened like yeah now I know you're a
big basketball fan and you mentioned how
you had to be on the wood I always tell
people once you sit on that wood one
time you can never go back it's done
even like row b it's like I'm sorry
the whole game is different what have
you learned being right there on the
wood
you know Kevin Hart said it I think in
one interview like wood etiquette and
all that like like
no but it's I mean it's it's totally
different athleticism people talking
trash like you really feel so part of it
um yeah and yeah I mean I think I think
it's just really cool to see I mean I to
be as big of a fan as I am and see like
how good they really are up close like
it's just insane and
um yeah I mean and nobody in front of
you which is nice like you get up and
come back down like it's it's just
different it's a different feel yeah
it's like you just have to be careful
not to be texting or something because
the ball
it's funny that
oh no how close you all are we saw that
he was at your match how did that
relationship come to fruition
yeah it's one of our play development
guys
um like I mean me and Bradley whatever
DM and stuff and always after the game
say what's up but I've been trying to
get him to come to the match for a
minute and then
it was actually funny because Rafael
Nadal is like one of he's like a huge
fan of his which was funny I was like
well I hope you're not coming to kill
him but so they got him to match I was
like all right cool and then yeah once
that he's like oh tennis is lit like
tennis is cool and I was like yo you got
to keep coming like this is like a thing
now so then I go again and then when
again and he's like I was like yo you
coming so it was interesting they took
at first he took like car service up
then into the sprinters and then for the
Sammy's like yo we taking the PJ
I was like yeah this is serious
yeah like what like wifey did a whole
Vlog about it and everything and it was
pretty cool but I mean pretty much like
he's I mean he's remembering me since I
was like 14 I've been coming to games
and
um yeah since he's been in the league I
remember his rookie season so he's
always seen me around but he didn't
really know like the magnitude of it
until now and that was my biggest moment
and he was there so we have a different
level of respect for each other now
that's so great he is like the nicest
kindest most supportive person he's been
on the show and he's just super
thoughtful and intentional way exactly
everything that he says and you can tell
with his friends that he genuinely cares
a lot so it's really cool that you have
that in your life with Bradley Bill
exactly yeah if he opens the door for
you he's he really likes it he doesn't
do it for everybody no for sure okay so
you're the perfect person to ask this
because obviously as a tennis player but
I know the appreciation that you have
for every other sport I was having this
debate with some friends the other day
about which four Sports have the best
athletes
so like which ones do you have to be the
most athletic to play
for sure hoops I think that's number one
right basketball for sure Hoops
um
I'm buying someone put tennis in there
yeah I think tennis does literally have
the best athletes
um
I'm I'm not gonna put baseball I'm not
gonna [ __ ] off I'm gonna put I'll put
football in there yeah on there so far
these are what I said my last one
um
I think I'm gonna go hockey really I
think we'll go hockey going to going to
hockey game live like being when we won
the we wanted Stanley Cup some years ago
I was like these guys are freak athletes
yeah okay hockey over soccer sorry yeah
sorry sorry sorry sorry that's that's
sorry
hockey Fizz yeah it sucks yeah soccer
that freak athletes yeah to be that yeah
you're right so we got the same we got
it yes we have the same we locked in we
locked in but somebody did try to say
baseball because they were like well
being a shortstop is so difficult I'm
like I'm not debating it's difficult but
in terms of like agility and speed and
endurance and just like strength those
other ones I don't even think it's not
even close you have to be able to go
yeah I saved you there because he didn't
say soccer yeah you know how they get up
um okay but as you go through all of
this right and you're you're meeting on
the people that you admire and you're
sitting on the wood and you're doing all
this cool stuff
how do you make sure that you don't get
caught up in being a star I have a
question
um
because the main thing is always the
main thing remember why uh you're
getting introduced all these things and
then why people want your attention
because of tenants right so
um keep that going and and keep doing
what you love like I mean at the end of
the day this is all cool but I still you
know 25 about to be 25 and a lot I have
a lot I want to achieve and a lot of
people want to inspire and and a lot of
people want to take care of basically my
family so
yeah I mean the main thing's the main
thing but it's not easy you get you
start getting like oh like you start
really feeling yourself so uh luckily
mom's humbles me so it's all love yeah I
was gonna say in those moments what is
it that you say to make sure you can
kind of halt I don't know if the ego is
the right word but you know halt that
feeling of like all right this is cool
is this the thing that matters you know
how do you bring yourself back I think I
think my parents are doing such a great
job of that like they're like is
constantly telling me like yo like this
is this is all great but like as fast as
it comes as fast it can go so
um and I'm like and I'm very worried
about that and
um I think they've done a great job
since I was young and kind of always
instill that in me and my friends as
well but yeah I mean kind of gets always
telling myself that there's more to come
right like this is just the beginning so
don't get uh too hyped about it even
though there's been some pretty dope
moments yeah but I mean I also think on
the flip side too it's really important
for people to step back and be proud of
the things that they've accomplished you
know and step back and say okay I
deserve to be in these rooms I have you
know I'm doing this thing I love and I'm
really successful at it so there's this
balance of okay enjoying it and doing
all those fun things but then also
remembering why and it feels like you
totally understand that kind of the
balance yeah that's a good question
though because I was getting I was
feeling myself big time a little bit ago
I had to bring myself back a little bit
really so watch this moment you're
thinking of you said I was feeling
myself a little minute ago when
um I mean literally right after like
there was this it was so much going on
like Fashion Week this and the other
everyone in Fashion Week like coming up
to me like people that I mean I would
dream about talking to congrats man we
was watching you do your little tennis
thing like almost crazy and we and it
gets and hilarious and then at home like
the day after me and everyone at home
like doing random things people be so
excited and uh yeah it definitely got to
me but and now I'm handling my career
yeah so so I mean I think that you are a
fantastic tennis player I think
everybody sees how talented you are when
you have this kind of you know this
coming out party that is such a huge
moment right and everybody is looking at
you and for some people this might have
been the first time that they heard your
name
how do you make sure that it isn't just
a moment does that make sense yeah yeah
I think a lot a lot of things change
like even with my team I'm like hey guys
like this is this is great we had a
great season stuff like that but let's
let's double down on everything we've
done looking like this dude is the same
thing right to try to get the same
result let's let's I mean let's really
put
put everything into it and and try to be
the best we can be like I mean let's
chase stars and and this Broncos say
Stratford rating so
um yeah I've started holding myself in
more accountable my team more
accountable and just uh yeah I mean I
want to win one of the big ones one day
yeah no I love that and I'm sure you
will I mean you're so young you have so
much ahead of you uh to be able to do
that so when I think about the moment uh
when you were in the U.S open I think
something that athletes say a lot is you
know of course I went into the game
knowing I was going to win you always
have this belief that you're going to
win you were facing Rafa right and so
it's very I'm sure intimidating to think
okay this is who I'm gonna face did you
really truly genuinely believe before
that like I can win this
um uh that morning yeah the night before
no I was stressed out I was like [ __ ]
sorry bro yeah yeah I was like but yeah
I was like man it's gonna be a tall
order and then
um yeah I mean I just feel really good
like in the morning but it's I mean it's
tough I mean he's like literally our guy
um Pinnacle of sports so
um I was like if I can get this crowd
behind me and and what have you so but
yeah I mean I felt really good like that
day I definitely believe that was gonna
win yeah what what gave you that
um they played a couple times before
um never in the U.S like so I knew I can
get the crowd with me I mean I knew if I
really you know brought my best stuff
had a chance because he had a little bit
of injuries going in so he wasn't 100
physically so
um I was like yeah let's kind of shake
the world today yeah I mean and you
really did like everybody you know was
watching was watching that moment have
you all spoken since that I mean yeah
yes
um
that's for sure
um but yeah you know we definitely did I
mean he's just congrats on what you've
been doing and that was that's super
cool hearing from him and
um but yeah you can definitely see he
wants to play me again you can see that
yeah okay so then what does that bring
out of you knowing that to him he's like
no we we're gonna run this yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're gonna
have to come see me again yeah it makes
me feel good like you know he's got a
different level respect for me now and
then also
um he's finally as a threat so it's you
know it's it's all love but yeah I'm
gonna have to be ready so next time we
see each other that's for sure so when
you think about the open right all of
much it's not just that one what is the
like immediate thought that comes to
your mind about that event
I mean this is a life change in two
weeks but I think it's one of the best
events in the world like I mean people
like
I mean who's who's coming to the matches
especially for tennis like it's cool to
see like you know it's like every night
there's you know someone super cool
coming and
um I just think it's just one of one of
the best events in the world to get be
like be a fan of
um you know I love I love seeing like
celebs join and want to watch the sport
I play and really enjoy and
um but then like one of the best
atmospheres out there like people are
just losing their heads which is not
normal in tennis like yeah so you know
everyone's drunk by four o'clock five
o'clock and you feed off them yeah
you're like please more drinks everyone
yeah so yeah so yeah it's it's it's up
and it's and it's New York and it's
energy it's a lecturik it's it's all
that you know like you can feel all that
when you're out there so
um yeah New York's one of my favorite
cities and that's one of my favorite
events but when you think about your
time at the US Open do you think about
your wins or your loss
damn I've actually never even thought
about it that way
um
to be honest with you probably the loss
I'm like I'm not gonna lie to you
because you're that close and I was like
damn like
and I really feel like the whole country
with me like you know I've really felt
like you know okay I'm gonna really do
it so maybe a bit hungrier but at the
same time like you had like that
breakthrough moment so kind of have in
half but definitely that loss I'm like
it was a great match and you know I wish
I wish you went a little different yeah
because you so when I was you know
prepping for this interview I saw a
quote that you said that I thought was
interesting uh that I want to ask you
about
you said I think it was great that I
actually didn't win the event I wonder
where I would be mentally if I did win
the event
what did you mean by that did your
homework Taylor I like that
I remember saying that I totally agree
like I I went to your question earlier
if you know like you know it's a new
stardom and what have you where would
you be at and
yeah I mean if I ended up with it I
don't I don't know where I'd be at like
because that was always the goal as a
kid and um to do it and you know
everything that comes after I probably
would have been pretty full like you
know now I'm like I want to get to it I
want to finish the job I want to I want
a case more and more you do it in that
moment
I don't know
but then it's easy to say that when you
lost but yeah you actually won how do
you feel but yeah that's that's how
again we felt that moment well that's
why I thought it was interesting because
I'm like okay do you feel that way
because you think that you know getting
the Big Win It would maybe make you
complacent because you accomplished the
thing that you yeah I think I think it
would have brought a big complacency
knowing my personality because you know
you do the work for those moments and
um
yeah and I would have just been a lot
like I just would have been like all
right cool I'm chilling I did what I
said I was going to do and here we go
but now you're saying like you got close
enough that it's going to fuel you to
actually cross that Finish Line yeah you
know it's possible so you know it's
possible because you got that close so
you know why not why not get it done and
see how good you can be so yeah I think
I think it happened for the best okay
biggest takeaway uh that you learn about
yourself personally personally and your
personality after uh the US Open and
biggest takeaway what you learned about
your game from the US okay well probably
some of my game first my game I really
believe that I'm one of the best players
in the world like at my best
um being mentally there locked in I'm
one of the best in the world and and
then you know
I mean personally that
[Music]
um
I'm a lot I'm a lot tougher than I
probably thought it was
um and that I can really dig deep and
you know play you know for x amount of
hours and really put my you know heart
on the line you know sometimes like
you know you get nervous and you kind of
like run away and make excuses and run
away from like the thick of the battle
but I think there I was you know I
approved myself that I can
withhold any kind of opposition yeah
I've talked about this a bunch on the
show I've said this quote but someone
once said to me that fear makes the wolf
bigger than he is and I think that when
you are facing somebody like an adult
right and you know who this person is
the thing that can sometimes defeat you
is actually that you're thinking about
them right like you're thinking about
the giant that is in front of you and it
takes a lot of mental fortitude to not
like back away from the Giant and to me
that is like the most impressive thing
about the win right if that makes sense
that mentally you were you weren't
intimidated by what we all know him to
be does that make sense exactly exactly
it's kind of like he's got to get over
that and that's why I said I think it
helps that put him a couple times before
that and get over that moment like if
because we all know who he is what he's
done
um all the accolades and what have you
but
um yeah a lot of times you play those
you know LeBron or you know Mount
Rushmore kind of guys I like to say like
you guys already you've already lost
before you got out there because you're
like oh I'm playing against LeBron or
you know I'm playing against Kevin
Durant or whoever and today's kids were
awful so yeah it was nice to to do it
yeah love that for you
um in so many sports though I think
we're seeing this like changing of the
guards like the new generation of who
like those future grades are going to be
right we're seeing it in basketball
we're seeing it in football I think
we're seeing it and Tennis a lot of ways
a lot of the people that we grew up
watching are either retiring or just
kind of entering into that space of
being done what do you attribute these
like multiple watershed moments in
multiple Sports too I I would literally
have a conversation the other day how
like I think the best
you know athletes of all sports were in
these last 20 years at the same time
which is just wild and they're all like
coming at the end
um right now and it's it's pretty it's
pretty crazy to see and there's just new
phases to everything I think I mean
honestly like people who think care
about their bodies so much more people
let teams know so much more I think
that's what's creating longevity for
them obviously
their one percenters of how good they
are at their particular sport but I
think everyone's taking I mean he's here
LeBron's Pace what two million a year on
his body you know what Tom Brady still
doing and still Blaze
yeah like that's a whole nother thing
like then you have like Matthew Ronaldo
like all these guys like so you gotta
test it to that for sure and but I'm
it's cool to see this new era and
um it's it's cool for me and and all the
other guys I'm sure so in this new era
what place do you feel like you're
you'll take
I think I'll be in one of the top spots
yeah I mean I want to be I want to yeah
I mean I want when you when we talk
about tennis you're
three four guys you're talking about
friends tiafa like you're like okay like
yeah tennis oh okay you kind of
different stuff I think because I
remember growing up anytime I tell
someone I play tennis in the hood oh
he's trying to be like Serene and veins
and that would be cool to be like oh you
can't be like Francis like and that's
that's kind of what I want to be had
what's greatness to you in tennis
um I mean for me I would call I would
say
I would leave the game saying I was
great if I after I played I was able to
create a streamline of players like
players who look like me to be able to
play the game and play the game at a
high level and
um and be able to do things I did
um in the game so I would say pretty
much
doing something at a high level and
inspiring some little kids that want to
do the same thing is greatness so then
what are your goals for 2023
I want to finish the top 10 in the world
right now I'm 19 so I'd love to think
it's top 10 in the world and I'd love to
win one of the four grand slams
preferably here in New York
um
here in here in Wimbledon they're like
my two always like lifetime dreams I
remember seeing like the Williams
sisters play and Wimbledon final and
stuff like that so I definitely want to
when we move in and hopefully this one
one of the two is fine
but two both of them would be great too
so we'll see what happens no I think
it's really beautiful how much you smile
when you talk about like you know the US
Open and just the goals that you have
for yourself because you're in such a
special time now that the world really
is right in front of you right like you
are controlling your destiny and it is
so based on like the things that you put
into it what you believe yourself to be
and I think that's that's just a really
nice pocket uh to be in to know that you
are in control of that you know for sure
do you feel that no absolutely
absolutely I want to say I would say
calling you to be my motivator it's so
great it's a great stuff here
no but you're totally right I mean
there's there's I mean there's an
opening and it's like whether you want
to really put everything into it and be
a part of it or he's going to hang out I
can watch other people do it so I've
always said you know why not you you
know you're doing the work and every day
you know so why not you so yeah so I
primarily cover a lot of MBA and NFL but
I do what yeah but I do you know watch
Tennis when I know everyone's watching
and I think it's a really fun thing I
love Serena
um but something that I've really
noticed about tennis is there seems to
be a lot of like tennis etiquette and
Tennis decorum and what people feel like
tennis players should be do you feel
like you're able to be yourself playing
this sport yeah I think that's been like
the best thing like for a guy like me
like I definitely shake things up you
know you know I'm saying come on a lot
I'm super loud I'm showing my
personality I'm shaking hands in the
crowd f-bombs this end whatever like I'm
just I'm I'm doing I'm being me
um and so yeah I mean
I definitely wouldn't say I have the
best etiquette I'm respected with my
opponent but I don't definitely want to
say I have like your classic tenants
etiquette I mean I always preach that
you're not going to go to a basketball
game and not say anything or you're not
gonna go to a football game or final
four or something like that and I think
for us to keep building the game and
having younger fans like you know you
want people like to really the fans and
everybody else to like to have like
Rowdy atmospheres and I think that's
what New York is so good yeah and I
think that's what makes it fun 100 yeah
like I want everyone to like do the most
yeah yeah like I'm like no you wanted
more of that yeah
no absolutely so I'm like keep doing all
those things it makes the crowd really
Rowdy as you said and I just think that
that like makes it a bit more
interesting
um after you one one time you wrote on
there I think it was be stronger than
your biggest excuse yes yes how is that
quote Applied to your life yes um
as you kind of talked about fear right
um and and those kind of things and
there's always excuses especially in
tennis like it's just you so if you're
not doing something you're not reaching
the goals you want to reach it's on you
you blame anybody you want but I mean
when people watch you you lose or or you
win so
um and that was kind of like my biggest
thing I've always left especially last
couple years like always had excuse of
why I wasn't doing X Y and Z and and
yeah it just kind of just be a man and
um yeah that's kind of what it meant to
me yeah I know I love that I've never
heard anybody say that quote is that
like Francis original
I'm not I'm not that I'm telling you I
heard that from from Inky Johnson
um he uh he put that up and I was like
I'm stealing that girl and I was hard
yeah no it's so good yeah okay wait so I
know I told you I love Serena you can
tell me it's just me and you nobody's
watching is she unretiring I mean what's
happening girl we coming back
what do you think happens you heard that
last speech that was that wasn't
that that wasn't telling me that last
speech he was she she was like
it didn't say like I'm I'm done yeah
she's kind of like oh yeah you know
I I mean look I I don't think she's
gonna retire I wanted to still play I
love seeing her around we all do yeah I
think the whole world does so I don't
think so I mean I think I mean the game
of mystery I mean the world's a mystery
so I mean I hope she comes back but I
said right away I was like nah she ain't
done [ __ ] she's like yeah I I think I
can do some more so we'll see yeah and
she even said she was like I mean
there's like a very strong possibility
that I that I'm back and I'm like well
wait what does this look like what's the
timeline what is it it'd be great it'd
be crazy announcement if you say you're
coming back too so well I mean we'll see
we'll see but I mean I don't think he's
done personally yeah no that's that's
what I hope fingers crossed come back
yeah we're not done with you please
don't be done with us
um you know I think in tennis though
there is a lot of sibling Duos which I
think is really cool why do you think
that is because I know even you and your
twin brother you both play obviously you
know the mcenrose the Williams like the
Murrays there's there's a lot of those
you know sisters Mr brother playing the
sport yeah I mean growing up playing and
playing you always have someone to play
with which is nice right and then you
guys coming to push each other and just
keep kind of going
um it's actually amazing how they were
able to do it because you know sometimes
one gets maybe a bit better than the
other and then you know you kind of lose
that Focus to the other one but yeah I
mean they were able to kind of keep it
going keeping focused on both people men
and women and yeah um but I think I
think it helps with growing up that you
always have someone to play with because
sometimes you maybe not have people to
play with or maybe it's too expensive to
go and play with somebody else so I
think that's probably why yeah and I
mean you and your brother's relationship
is so special and there was an article
where he was talking about you know you
being a great tennis player and I think
he said I want to be known as Franklin
TFO not francis's brother so in the
interactions that you all have how do
you balance you know him you know that
importance of individuality and knowing
how much you believe in him as well no
for sure for sure I've pushed that much
to him a lot like
um
because I mean
I just tell them that you don't have to
figure out life today right like I mean
everyone's gonna have their own their
own way and and think how they do things
um don't don't let the media or people
just say because everything's about
friends people are you friends with
brother like Franklin CFO has a whole
life as he's gonna have and
um he's gonna be one of one of the best
Brothers in the world he's gonna be a
husband one day and he's gonna be a dad
and he's gonna also achieve some great
things so keep doing your thing and and
don't worry about anything else because
our relationship stays the same I'm
gonna love you regardless oh I love that
what's the best part of having a twin
you know growing up everyone's like I
want a twin it'd be so cool like what
what do you love about about having a
twin
um I mean just growing up like you know
like we're doing everything together
like I mean from having our first
greetings to you know everything like
where every week it's the same age at
all times and then how we
he's gonna like he'll pick up some of
the things I'm gonna say like as I'm
thinking it we're always like thinking
the same thing that's like a real thing
and it's cool like give me an example
because people say that and it's like
you just know exactly Hill Financial
sentences for me like if I'm like trying
to get something out and like it's in my
head and like he'll say it and that's
like yeah that's what he's trying to say
how'd you know and
um like things like that and
um and it's like weird like you can if
I'm even not with him like I can call
him and be like yo thumbs up I know
you're not feeling well today like that
I feel like you're not feeling well and
he's like yeah bro like and then like
vice versa like it's crazy like it's
like twin stuff's like real I wonder
what the science behind it I I do it's
you know
the person's feelings
yeah
yeah
like it's crazy it's crazy but I feel
like everyone that I know is a twin like
has stories like that you're just so
interconnected and like really special
ways no I think it's it's really
beautiful you have somebody else on
Earth who understands you in a way that
like most people will never experience
you know which is which is really cool
yeah you have siblings no I do yes I
have a younger sister we're not twins
obviously we're six years apart but you
know I think it's different being the
older one you know what I mean like you
just feel a different sort of like
responsibility whereas I feel like if I
had a twin I'd be like oh this is my dog
like this is who I'm with all the time
you know I almost feel like I'm more of
her like protector but I'm sure in some
ways you all feel like you're protecting
each other as well but there's like a
relatability that you all have that I
think is different than when there is
like that that sort of age Gap exactly
exactly exactly is that your only
sibling yeah okay yeah so you're like I
only know having a twin yeah no well
that's that's so nice for sure you know
I think everybody really knows that you
know your family story you know your the
child of immigrants you know your dad
was working the grounds at a tennis
center I know sometimes I think I read
that you all would you know sleep in the
training room and you had you know a
difficult upbringing in some ways but I
have you really sat back and thought
that like your existence has like
changed the trajectory of your family's
life yeah I was doing um
yeah I mean I was doing
um a film the other day and you know I
had to go I had to go back to where I
grew up and I haven't been there
obviously like eight years and and while
I was there someone I pulled the car
down was like oh man I remember Living
Next To You
and his kids were like yeah and I was
like damn like you know like if it
wasn't for tennis like [ __ ] I'd probably
be here too like you know and
um that just really hit me that got me
really emotional and I was like man
that's why uh you can see what hitting
the tennis ball like you know put my
family and it was interesting like from
a young age like
you know my parents go like you know
being for Sierra Leone and coming here
having twins was like if we if through
tennis y'all can get a full scholarship
that would be like a dream
and I was like yeah it would be but you
know me being able to play tennis and
taking care of y'all and
um putting you all in better positions
that would be a dream like that would be
like the best thing possible and that's
what I wanted to do and and yeah I think
having that Vision infrastructure young
age was why we're here having this
conversation yeah no I think that's so
beautiful and I mean I'm sure there have
been so many different times in your
life that you have told your parents you
know how thankful you are for them what
they have been to you and what they have
given you in terms of like believing in
you to do this but like what is the real
thing that you would say to them about
how they're nurturing and their love
allowed you to become Who You Are
um
I mean
yeah I mean they were always there for
me like they were always you know like
friends you want to do this you want to
be a pro but like if you don't get there
don't be discouraged to be always gonna
love you and then and I was like wow
that gave me a ton of confidence because
it was like all right well even if I
don't do this at a high level my parents
are going to be there for me they love
me and as a kid like that that's huge
right like because a lot of times you
know you get some you know some parents
or relationships with kids like you know
they look frowned upon like if you're
not doing things at a high level or
whatever
um so that was big for me and then
yeah I mean I kind of just
um they they really preached the work
ethic and then seeing what they were
doing my dad's working like 16 hour
shifts like cleaning place all day my
mom working two jobs as a nurse that's
why we would stay over
um at the tennis center and we sleep at
the training training room and my mom
was working her two jobs so I'm looking
around as a kid like man these guys are
putting hours in just just you know
break even put food on table for my
brother and I and I was like man like
you can't not put the work in like you
can't not act like oh because we're in
America and kind of just like slouched
around and like you know take this for
granted because essentially we shouldn't
be at this Tennis Academy so yeah
um if my dad wasn't working so yeah I
think I think from a young age that like
and they push that constantly like we're
giving you guys a chance and then when
they took us to Sierra Leone when we
were like eight years old yeah I was
that woke me up yeah because they were
like this is this is what we had
this is what this is what our life
looked like yeah and you go in the
states and have a chance and
yeah from that moment everything kind of
changed
something that is like fascinating to me
and obviously everyone's experience is
different but kind of the magic of
parents is
they do such a good job of not making
children realize
that there's a struggle
I will say you know we'll say because
growing up like people like man your
story was so tough was it like
I mean [ __ ] like I had a great time like
I was like I mean like I didn't feel
like I was in this like
I didn't feel like people had to feel
sorry for me I didn't feel like you know
I was behind the eight ball by any means
like
in in the obvious sense yes like I mean
we had like senator's kids at the
Academy but like
I mean to me I was like you know I was
playing with kids and whatever like you
know it was all love but
um when you look back at it now like
damn that was that was crazy like when
people say it out loud like oh man
that's your story but yeah to your point
like they did an unbelievable job like
they would just say look look at it
around you look at the opportunity
rather than man this is tough man like
you never I never saw him like
complaining about how hard it was never
that's why sometimes you know I wish
that when we talked about athletes and
upbringings that are maybe different
than others that it's not always framed
about the hard Parts it's more so framed
about like the love that surrounded them
that allowed them to become those people
you know because I just I don't ever
want people to get too caught up in
what they almost feel like is trauma
right when really like you were
surrounded by people who loved you and
cared about you and believed in you they
gave you all of the tools that you
needed to in turn believe in yourself
you know and that's what it just I think
makes being a parent so like sometimes
I'm like how is anybody a parent like
it's so much all the time I love kids
but dang I love them so much that you
just like always want them to be
yeah to the things right away yeah yeah
it's crazy like their life is in your
hands see if you make and stuff like
that it's crazy anyway so what do you
love most about your parents
[Music]
um
I think that they they still treat me as
their son they have none of none of all
the stuff that I've done shakes them but
anyway like
Mama met LeBron today like it was super
cool I'm glad you had fun yeah
it's just things like that that is super
funny like they just none of these
things like in the moment they're happy
for me and all those things but like
um yeah I think you know growing African
parents are just so like
you're my son you're still a kid like 25
years old like if I curse in front of
them they look at me like crazy like
like so like it's so that's I think
that's that's what I love because
um our you know mother son father-son
relationship hasn't changed since I was
a kid so yeah um I still feel that
respect that like even scared like even
saying certain things to them yeah and
uh I hope I keep that forever no that's
beautiful and also I guarantee that your
mom's favorite thing and isn't even just
watching you play it's that you're why
she met Michelle Obama oh yes yeah yeah
yeah that's what parents like it's like
okay who am I gonna meet because my kid
is doing this like she's like probably
cherishing that that much yeah she was
hugging Michelle like crazy like hooking
wrong see you surface looking at it like
man you crazy can't be doing that so
yeah yeah it was funny man it's awesome
okay so we are definitely like
manifesters on this show so before we go
I want you to tell me the four celebs
that you haven't met that you want to is
you continue this greatness throughout
your career
[Music]
um
yeah but Brian's out the way uh
Denzel
good one Denzel big one Viola Davis oh
why have Iola I love Violet Davis nah
she's like one of my biggest
Inspirations like her movies are insane
um plays a role like and I was I
honestly don't think she actually gets
as much love as she deserves to be
honest totally she's like one of the
greatest actresses of like our
generation yeah totally he's crazy yeah
um I would definitely then say
I'm a big fan of uh Michael B Jordan as
well okay I think that it is and
um
Taraji P Henson oh okay you're big into
like the entertainment space
we can help you with Michael B he's been
on the show yeah where do you live are
you in DC I'm in DC okay when you're
when you're in La next tell man if he's
there I'll try to I'll try to connect
you too he was crazy and Creed I thought
like I really loved my Creed but uh yeah
throughout your fiance and like I always
like she's as funny as hell yeah
actually sorry sorry not too early she's
probably My Fit get real Union I bet
that's like oh yeah growing up she was
like my celebrity crush yeah you're like
so I got him I gotta meet her okay three
athletes that you have at math that you
want to meet three athletes
um
uh
uh Michael Jordan for sure he's like a
unicorn just floating somewhere in the
world like people like do not see him a
lot so like Michael Jordan's a good one
Michael Jordan and Tiger Woods same
thing and uh
I feel like telling bro I feel like you
just got to meet the goats oh totally
yeah I feel like those those would be
that would be super cool yeah well I
think that you have such a beautiful
energy I think that for so many of us it
was a joy and a treat to be able to
watch you in the US Open and I'm so
excited to continue watching your career
and I have no doubt that you will meet
all those people that you just said
because
I gotta add in Drake because Drake he's
like yes all the time like he's like
yeah oh when I see the owl yeah yeah
yeah baby so he's like Drake what that's
my guys do you like her loss oh it's so
good so good yeah so good yeah what's
your favorite song on there
um
Josh's little twin bro that's a good one
he loved jumping
jump in the name so if anything let that
be your inspiration exactly
one day you're in
the saw your time it truly was a
pleasure thank you appreciate it
absolutely
[Music]